A tourist, according to the World Tourism Organization, a United Nations body,...
...is someone who travels at least 80 kilometers from home for the purpose of recreation.
A wider definition is that tourism is a service industry.
It covers a number of tangible and intangible aspects.
The tangible aspects are transport systems: air, rail, road, water and now, space.
Other examples are hospitality services: accommodation, foods and beverages, tours, souvenirs.
And then there are services such as banking, insurance and security.
Examples of intangible elements are rest and relaxation, culture, escape, adventure.
These are the things you experience.
The intangible aspects of tourism are perhaps even more important than the tangible ones.